well our exclusive continues with Mariah
Carey we were the only one she talked to
backstage in Paris and you know
everything in Raya says and does is so
delicious that we put together Mimi's me
mobile moment we were obsessed with the
Instagram picture of you making a pizza
well it was a silk neck kind of
nightgowns a negligee I wear negligee at
home and then I wear regular clothes
when I have to classic but how about
mimi's reacted to missing the American
Idol finale oh I was devastated that I
couldn't be there I almost lost my mind
I didn't know what the hell to do I had
to go home and like ice my head it's
just me I can't help it this is just me
I'm just trying to be I don't even know
what it is asperger thoughts on filming
a docu-series I'm like cameras really
i'm dressing and her haters haters gonna
hate players gonna believe them I've
never even met them before and now a
look inside Mariah's Paris dressing room
velvet curtains scented candles soft
lighting and why what are your dressing
room essentials do I have any do I get
any I think I get done you want to know
my one here here here right here the
lamb lamb deepal those are gifts from
her fans who call themselves lambs and
Mariah puts them to good use like
covering up the girls so we don't have
to buy Lambie
you